tellement aux veines ça coule des cent
des français parce que j'ai des 100
métis et des premières nations ma grand
mère c'était un cri mon père une par les
cris lancés en anglais
ma mère c'est un britannique qui
viennent de l'angleterre n'avait pas
d'éducation ma mère mes dents - me sens
à l'aise dans tous les groupes avoir des
capacités de parler avec toutes ces
mondes et comprendre comment ils pensent
et creusement plus important si on a
déjà eu des candidats qui parlent et ils
disent quelque chose qui est
complètement farfelu et j'essaie d'être
le plus compréhensif pc la beauté des
apprenants quand on frappe aux log deux
cas passé de le culte
merci d'apporter des preuves militaire
pendant dix huit ans amandine et d'avoir
la capacité de prendre des décisions